[Música]
danny economía mañana movida como le
estaba diciendo a rosa ya nos estábamos
esperando porque las peticiones de
renuncia dan y de boris johnson venían
desde su mismo equipo económico claro es
que recuerdo este de richi es una claro
él era el ministro de finanzas uno de
los ministros estrella de boris johnson
hasta hace dos días y a quien se le
atribuye pues muchos de los subsidios a
las empresas durante la pandemia
subsidios también a los a los salarios
de los trabajadores esto para poder de
llevar la economía por una senda de
crecimiento pues él se fue justamente
argumentando que su enfoque para
administrar la economía era muy
diferente al de boris johnson y en su
reemplazo a encendió el ex titular de
educación en nadie zawi recién
posesionado ayer es el nuevo ministro de
finanzas dijo compartir este enfoque de
boris johnson sobre mantener la
disciplina fiscal pero bastaron apenas
pocas horas raúl para que se uniera a
estas voces que pedían la renuncia de
boris johnson en su cuenta de twitter
reveló en la madrugada la madrugada del
jueves que le pidió a boris johnson dar
un paso al costado por dignidad lo dice
él concretamente aseguró lo siguiente
el primer ministro eso no es sostenible
y sólo empeorará para usted para el
partido conservador y lo más importante
para el país debe hacer lo correcto e
irse ahora como danny como marcha
entonces en la economía británica
reuniré la economía del reino unido
lucha bajo la presión de una inflación
de casi dos dígitos también con una
desaceleración que parece ser inclusive
más severa que en la mayoría de otras
grandes naciones del mundo miremos ahora
por los datos macroeconómicos navegamos
por los datos macroeconómicos del reino
unido mira tino inflación interanual del
9,1 por ciento esto es un máximo de 40
años y la cifra es hasta mayo es mucho
más alta que sus países vecinos
recordemos que en europa más o menos es
como del 8% del 8.3 por ciento y también
es tan recordado pero la del reino unido
va en 91 por ciento inclusive el banco
central de inglaterra ha pronosticado
que llegaría al 11 por ciento en
cuestión de pocos meses y por eso es que
ha venido endureciendo su política con
de aumentos en las tasas de interés
cuando el reino unido- las tasas de
interés siempre han estado muy pegadas
al 0% danny le pregunto cómo está
entonces en este momento el producto
interno bruto británico y de la economía
británica se contrajo inesperadamente en
abril en 0.3 por ciento después de haber
caído también en marzo esto elevó los
temores de una fuerte desaceleración
porque se trata de las primeras caídas
consecutivas desde abril y marzo de 2020
cuando se dio el inicio pues de la
pandemia el fondo monetario
internacional pronosticó hace un par de
meses que gran bretaña en 2023 iba a
enfrentar un crecimiento económico más
lento y una inflación más persistente
que cualquier otra economía importante
del mundo pero quizás otra de las áreas
más apremiantes del país en este momento
como lo decía también luisa pulido de
nuestra corresponsal en londres el
lograr esa resolución de un asunto
todavía inconcluso del presi con la
unión europea concretamente a lo
relacionado a las reglas comerciales
para irlanda del norte que están
implicando mayores barreras para las
exportaciones británicas al bloque de
los 27 pero se me quedó un dato raúl y
en del de desempleo mire en cuanto al
mercado laboral la tasa de desempleo
viene aumentando por primera vez desde
finales de 2020 los meses terminaban los
tres meses terminados en abril de 2022
se ubicó en 38 por ciento aunque es una
cifra baja pues ya quisiéramos en
américa lo tener dinero a una cifra el
3,2 por ciento danny usted lo sabe mejor
que yo porque es que uno de los
principales problemas económicos del
reino unido es la enorme carga de la
deuda qué tan grande es esta carga de
deuda que tiene reino unido mire el
reino unido hoy en día tiene una deuda
de casi 24 billones de dólares que según
la oficina de responsabilidad
presupuestaria es insostenible de cara
al futuro
de hecho a menudo se informó que varios
johnson y su exministro receipts un acre
de quien hablábamos hace unos instantes
estaban en desacuerdo sobre cuánto más
debería pedir prestado el gobierno la
deuda de los países se mide de raúl
generalmente como porcentaje del
producto interno bruto cuánto debe
versus cuánto les ingresa en toda la
economía hoy la deuda del reino unido
desde el 96% sobre ese producto interno
bruto y si nos ponemos a hacer algunas
comparaciones vemos por ejemplo que en
un país muy endeudado como argentina la
deuda es de entre el 70 y el 80 por
ciento del pib en eeuu es de más del 100
por ciento pero eso es como consecuencia
de la gran deuda que se acumuló durante
la pandemia y japón debe el doble de su
pib usted buena sacando conclusiones
usted buen analizando cifras del pasado
para saber evidentemente como se va a
comportar entonces la economía y las
cosas en un futuro por eso le pregunto
que se prevé para reino unido en el
tiempo venidero bueno yo sólo dejo los
expertos por ejemplo la oficina de
responsabilidad presupuestaria ellos
creen que si las cosas siguen como van y
gran bretaña no endurece sus políticas
fiscales ese porcentaje del que
estábamos hablando del 96 por ciento
actual se va a triplicar al 320 por
ciento dentro de 50 años y eso que
implica raúl aumentar impuestos o sea se
deben aumentar impuestos para financiar
los crecientes costos de una población
que se está envejeciendo y que está
saliendo del mercado laboral
buscar más fuentes de recursos porque el
gobierno se comprometió a prohibir la
venta de automóviles nuevos a gasolina
ya diesel a partir del 2030 y son
precisamente los aranceles sobre ese
combustible una gran fuente de ingresos
fiscales mientras que la electricidad se
graba de manera muy ligera y todos le
están apostando es a los vehículos
eléctricos vamos a ver dani y le
pregunto si esta noticia afectó a los
mercados afectó las bolsas imagino que
tuvo implicaciones pero como estuvieron
bueno mire las noticias sobre boris
johnson ayudaron a impulsar si el índice
principal de la bolsa de londres que es
el es el footsie-100 a máximos de una
semana a media jornada avanzaba más del
1 por ciento pero eso está en línea con
otros mercados vecinos como parís madrid
y francfort así que algunos analistas
dice que no necesariamente tiene que ver
con la renuncia de johnson al tiempo la
libra esterlina se está fortaleciendo
tímidamente frente al dólar después de
que en estos días si hubiera cotizado en
su nivel más bajo en dos años cifra el
día daniele imagino por supuesto que
tiene que ver con el reino unido tiene
que ver con el reino unido- y es una
cifra de simpática porque mire 50 libras
esterlinas en ese momento equivalía a 65
54 dólares y fue la multa que pagó en
abril
boris johnson por incumplir las normas
de confinamiento que él mismo ayudó a
elaborar durante la pandemia el valor no
fue dado a conocer abiertamente pero
muchos de los medios locales lo
revelaron el mismo morbo josh johnson
hay que decirlo también raúl advirtió un
par de meses antes de que le impusieran
esta multa que los británicos que
incumplieran las instrucciones del
gobierno de quedarse en su casa se
enfrentaban a multas inmediatas de 30
libras unos 35 dólares que según
palabras del líder británico podrían
haber aumentado significativamente si
era necesario pues mire ahí resultó el
tomando de su propia medicina así de
jani pero también como lo hablamos con
el invitado y como rosa esto resultó
siendo más bien una una evidentemente
una multa moral no
simbólica claro diciendo usted no puede
hacer lo que quiera así sea el primer
ministro y como también lo libro se fue
el primer ministro multado en funciones
digamos en el cargo ambas por este
escándalo
triste no claro en ese momento fue
bastante criticado porque decían que él
se saltó la norma no solamente una vez
sino varias veces entonces esta multa de
50 libras esterlinas que realmente
simbólica y sobre todo para una persona
como él pues se quedó corta para el daño
que dice la gente que le hizo al país y
pues es que terminó entre otras cosas en
su renuncia an y muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica por supuesto más adelante más
a economía y nos vamos directo hasta
londres porque volvemos a comenzar